[Music]
are you hot for
anyone Lisa does he have more of a
basketball b or a football B he doesn't
play
sports my Tender Is grave I talked to
him I wish I was with
you that's really weird
[Music]
Lisa
you hear that I'm sure it's the girl
next door she's very
odd your
H I can't believe you're here do you
like music I have the Cure oh not that
kind of cure they can't make you better
I mean they can but like emotionally no
don't cry your tears just smell so
bad send it back need a friend no I love
it it's not really my
style when you're in doubt L looks good
she could probably even do pageants if
she had
Congeniality your daughter is a little
psycho I open my glorious home to an
ungrateful
little I want to help you but Taffy says
it's a waste of time to try and fix a
way he's better just accept a guy's
father oh that's so
cute I have an idea there are bad people
out there come on Lea it'll feel
good that hand is going to do terrible
things I'm
sry you are being admitted impatient
lock
down I could get the clink for life or
the electric chair but I don't want to
die a
virgin you know anything about The
Disappearance of a
student I'm not making any more
comments you can talk to my lawyer
really hope this goth phase in soon need
a won't you hi to
sin these songs of freedom cuz all I
ever
have Redemption
songs when you write
that all my
[Applause]
life are you ready for Bob Marley and
the don't let them fool you H oh no is
the people
music you know you're a
superstar I am a
superstar you can't separate the music
and the message you see reg music come
for unify the people not Everyone likes
what you're saying for your own safety
you need to
[Music]
stop December 3rd 1976 would be
assassins invaded Bob Marley's home and
attempted to take the life of the singer
his wife and do worry about that don't
worry
about every little going to be all right
you like that one
yeah there's a war going on oh I can
bring peace I can't even get peace from
myself rise up this
morning smile with the Rising Sun Three
Little
Birds it's by my
doorstep
sometimes the messenger has to become
the
[Music]
message Bob I know it's
dangerous right but you're the only one
who can unite the
people you're ready Bob
no guns can stop this
message I want the World to
[Music]
Change and that time is
[Applause]
no this is my message to
you
[Music]
don't l
k
[Music]
for
fore
[Music]
foreign
KRA
[Music]
project Leal a
chaos
I know what they say about
me about hopeless
Romantics that we're
weak and I'm not
weak I learned the hard
way not all love stories have a happy
ending turn up let's pick this back up
next week I just to what are you guys
doing here we think you might be a sex
addict every time I see you what
maybe I'm still
in
you thir times a charm this guy don't
stand a chance this is me haven't been
sleeping well
lately I guess I never
have when I was little I used to share a
room with my sister
she used to sleep so peacefully this is
me and I just used to lie there awake
[Music]
thinking how does anybody sleep that way
when your heart never goes to
sleep I know you feel like nobody gets
you I don't even get me this me it's
never enough for you he's a liar I've
never lied to you the constant criticism
she thinks I'm her
employee being with you feels like
home but I left home for a
reason whenever someone asked me what I
wanted to be when I grew
up my answer was
always in
love you must respect the Ed and flow of
the universe this is
me this is is me
[Music]
now hey come on get your stuff let's
go
let's try that
[Music]
again a week ago I spent my life racing
against time I'm going to help you out
today okay trying to save people who
were running out of it get until one
moment changed
everything come on Welcome Back to the
land that we're
living I don't understand what's
happening I've been having
Vision I knew he was going to
die I think I'm seeing the
future New York City is a whole new
level of crazy these days what do you
want
me York City is a whole new level of
crazy these days this is an emergency
get off the train that man's trying to
kill you what who are you what is going
on I can see the
future oh what the hell she didn't see
that coming that's not how it
works I've seen that man before so who
this Ezekiel Sims he was in the Amazon
with my mom when she was researching
spiders right before she
died wait I recognize you you live in my
building you're the paramedic yeah you
almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how
we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all
day
do you have no idea what those girls
have
[Applause]
come I think he can see into the future
are he's trying to change what
happens Julia get
down why AR scared why do your future
almost so
different if you want to live you have
to trust
me get
ready
now you're showing off maybe a
little I certainly hope you dance as
well as as you
dress there's only one way to find
[Music]
out you and I we're not so different
agent
our it'll help hold
[Music]
on the book is phenomenal sweetie but
what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother ell it's called a
copout whoa hey there's a cat in
there oh my God you're Ellie freaking
Conway author of ARG series ell
Conway I am such a fan oh yeah what is
it you do Espionage would you sign my
book here we
go
I love this
book come
[Music]
on who are these people real life spies
why would they care about me because
you're a goddamn Fortune tiller
ell what you wrote in your new book
actually happened and you kicked a
hornet nest you didn't even know existed
I'm in some really big trouble
Mom oh so now you're experimenting with
drugs I want all assets on them now I
need her to write the next
chapter God I hate that
cat
a too
yeah it's time for you to meet the real
agent
our oh my God oh my God oh my
God my name is Sharon I'm just a ticked
off hairdresser with us what in headache
I'm good at plenty of things taking No
for answer ain't one of
them you just wandered into a lady you
never met before his funeral why exactly
something about that little girl just
five and she already needs a liver
[Music]
transplant hi Sharon remember me yes
ma'am so she's going to help out a few
nights a week I met this woman she's a
mess perfect she fit right
in I'm going to put together together a
press kit for Michelle get corporate
donations that kind of thing we don't
need to be running around worried about
money and bills right now I just want to
be with my family that's about saying
yes and then figuring out how girls help
your daddy
out I'm not comfortable with this I'm
her father I'm supposed to be the one
taking care of her you're going to have
to get comfortable being uncomfortable
cuz this ain't about you it's about your
little girl when breaking sh will need
to fly to the Children's Hospital
immediately I've had patients who have
missed that window because they couldn't
get a flight now lose your faith over
this officials are saying be prepared
for what they're calling the worst
blizzard in State
history is
it
today okay we'll be
there you want to go on an adventure i w
let you go
the roads haven't been plowed the the
airport's closed honey listen it's it's
too dangerous I have to make it this is
our last chance if we don't take it
Michelle
[Music]
dies someone's got to do something
someone's got to fight
for but one thing I know for sure that
little girl now has the entire city
rooting for
[Music]
her want you to know something you're
not just worthy Sharon you're a
[Music]
miracle you want to be a normal teenager
I got news for you you're not normal
Doris who's
Doris uh I
am do you think this is the right place
for him you say that about any place my
brother's dying he hasn't hasn't talked
in years I'm so sorry my wife passed
away my dad died when I was three Christ
it ain't
competition I think I should start
sleeping at Sun Co so your brother
doesn't get too lonely he's my child
when he's in pain I'm in pain I'm your
child too what about God's sake give me
a break you can come to my house if you
need to place a party my mom won't be
there and you can do whatever you want I
I I have to tell everybody um but who
who are
you
everyone says this neighborhood is scary
but like when you're in it it's like not
that
scary thank
you it's really hard taking care of sick
people sometimes you need a
break I dare need to kiss
D he could have died and you weren't
here once your brother's gone he's
gone and you will miss taken care of him
you'll miss everything all the good all
the
bad we're going to have fun again you
and
me I'll learn how to be fun
again Doris old lady's name it was my
grandma's name oh she died the day I was
born my God is there any conversation
with you that is not like thoroughly
depressing
[Music]
me everyone ready okay here we go that
is Maurice the Great Tiger Warrior and
that is Junior his son the little tiger
Warrior over there is Patricia and that
is Miguel and there is the brains of the
bunch it's me Gilbert our mission if we
choose to accept it is to come to the
help of any animal who needs it all
right Betty by great tiger Warriors need
their sleep too and it's not as if bad
guys are going to come and attack Us in
the
night tonight begins a brand new era for
the jungle tonight history will be
Rewritten the jungle is covered with a
dangerous substance that if it comes
into contact with water will destroy all
vegetation I got to have a pee
pee what can we do about it well uh we
need an antidote that will save the
jungle it can only be found in one place
and it's far far away it's one of the
most dangerous places on Earth dangerous
come on how bad can it
[Music]
be hi there friend can you help
us
oh boy Miguel St nasty
Panda you have to stop them understood
yes yes we did it
Yori wow this is a perfect little boat
come on we've got a jungle to save here
we
go when the storms come the jungle will
be transformed into a desert oh no no
don't worry Gilbert we'll help yep and
we'll do do it in someone stop that
TI you're forcing me to pull out all the
stops
[Music]
Arnold yep I knew it we're going to
fight what was your plan back
there
it's like a 14-hour drive to get to
Santa Fe didn't think that far ahead to
be honest dad you're pretty out of shape
[Music]
though are you
hungry a sweet tooth you got from
me
oh is that all I got from
you somebody order a
stripper can I get you anything I'll
take a
beer
oh hey oh okay let's go no we're just
having a conversation excuse me 12 hours
ago 12 hours ago you
odit trust me this path you're on is not
worth it what do you care you're an
addict guess who I've learned that
[Music]
from Up there and um my life started to
slip away I just couldn't
stop I didn't really know what it meant
to be a
father but I would like to get to know
you why would I ever trust you you've
never been there for me
Dad I'm just trying to find my
daughter
[Music]
[Applause]
live your
life there's something greater something
better come
on come on but I don't care what they
say I'm in love with you they try to
pull me away but they don't
know
are you
okay 32-year-old Beacon Hill resident
Megan rhs had been assumed dead by the
police after she disappeared from a
nearby parking garage nearly 6 months
earlier
sorry my great-grandfather bought this
place in the 20s I
think it's pretty empty in the winter
good I'm really sorry about what
happened to you thank you is anyone else
coming down doubt
it Meg I'm sorry this is my cousin
meline we've got a big family I won't
hold it against you
after what you went through you'll never
feel normal again how are you guys
related her cousins there's just
something off about her what are you
nervous about is it all the talk of
death I think I saw your mother she
hasn't left that room in
[Music]
months you remember what Dr Potter said
sometimes nightmares can feel really
real why did you bring me here
where were
you when I was
gone you're broken you can't tell what's
[Music]
real
oh
hi
3 2
[Applause]
1 foreign
spee
speech
[Music]
the case s
to not on your
life hello
girls it's the last body shot
competition so we are going to Salt you
up I've had it with love I don't believe
it's relevant to the 21st century
lesbian you're not wearing that I just
came from work I came from Toledo I
don't dress like it I'm not here to
Pedal my
wees I'm leaving town I am too that was
my plan where are you going tell I
Florida I've been unhappy that's why we
take this trip together honey babe we
get our act together together cly's
driveway Pennsylvania's most trusted
name in car delivery curly here don't
call me
curly and your name curly my name is
Curly we just met it's too
familiar we're here from the car wait a
minute you call with a drop off in
Tallahassee and then these broads come
in and say they're ready to go to
Tallahassee they drive the car instead
of you is that bad bad if they find the
goods what we should see what's in here
bet it's
[Music]
[Applause]
locked I understand that you're unhappy
sir we will find and deliver the package
we just want your
friends you cannot relate to the public
which in the service profession is a big
hand did the two creeps find you they
know we have their stuff maybe we sell
it back shake them down are they like
wanted or something oh no they're not in
trouble at all I'm going to help you
break a big murder case that is about
the dumbest thing I've ever heard and
I'm a
cop who are you
Democrats
wow you've had a full
day look at that this is actually a
depiction of a swan but what do you see
what do you feel I feel you don't live
here Ronnie she could stay here but I
can't get a dog she's my sister there's
a difference yeah there's a difference
you can have sex in front of a dog it is
a big day for Anna they're doing one of
those big
auctions if I want to work at a top Art
G I got to get a good recommendation and
there is no better recommendation than
Claire
Dupont good morning everyone win's
clients are about to walk through that
door and I will not allow them to see
anything less than Perfection you what's
that massive oil spill on the back of
your shirt it's not like we work for a
sociopathic perfectionist or anything oh
God hello it's Claire your boss I need
an extra assistant I just got invited to
go to London with Claire DuPont
you're not on this flight I put you on
one that leaves in 4 hours an economy
you've just been upgraded first
class I'm William what brings you to
London our London branch has called in
the director of the New York office wow
you seem a bit young to be the director
yeah the youngest director in company
history if you're not too busy being a
Swanky art director I would love to take
you out I lied to him about so many
things you are here for work not for
play I got you the reservation tickets
for this
evening going to invite me inside excuse
me what happened to your manners down
tabi mom she's a director of an auction
house in New
York I would like you in charge of my
auction I'm going to do it I'm jealous
of your Hannah Montana
lifestyle
Sant us a word
please you're a New Yorker and being a
New Yorker means that you fight every
single
day Rocky babo said that isn't he from
Philly he moved there from
[Music]
Brooklyn
such a morbid
imagination bringing dead
things to
life hey she emerges from her cave hello
when do you think you finished this film
with yours I don't
know
what's all that stuff it's called stop
motion animation what do you think it's
a bit boring it's not finished it's not
boring make a new one a new one yeah I
know better story you want to hear
[Music]
it there's a
girl she's
scared there's someone
coming
who's coming the man no one wants to
meet the
Ashman you can bring it to
[Music]
life what does the Ashman do don't be
scared whatever it is you think you saw
back there it's not
real
I don't want to make this film
anymore you want to hear the next bit of
the
story I want to go I want to
go what happens when it takes on a life
of its
own
[Music]
wait wait wait hold on you okay yeah
great okay I'll be right back
get
[Music]
underwear Tom are you okay do I know you
man no but I been watching over you you
your whole life who are
[Music]
you wa I know it's cool your grandmother
was a guardian sworn to protect
Humanity now the duty of protecting it
is yours very funny right it's time to
start your training oh it's
[Music]
on whoa okay hold on oh no no no
no wait how did you know I was going to
survive I didn't is that a
dragon show off it will be my honor to
guide you wait we're getting dim some
not everything is what it seems
[Music]
kid
zodiac sworn to protect the guardian
who's the featherweight hi I'm Tom
lactose intolerant and guardian of a
Steph Curry rookie card
what feel the power in inside you oh
yeah wait you don't talk too do you this
about to be
on we need you for what's
coming who said kids can't fly I hope
you ain't afraid I don't know if I can
be who you need me to be your grandma
believed in you it's in your blood you
strong I've waited a thousand years for
this
moment
I am the guardian we've got this zodiac
up oh
yeah you know that it's
[Music]
coming RI come work for uncle s Secret
Service
Daddy get some sleep K I need your fresh
tomorrow what happens tomorrow one of my
agents called in sick you're on Air
Force
One Dam I break this one in yes
sir it's all yours General this a
president sit back and enjoy the
rides let's the onle we have to take the
pl back remember kid we only have one
job protect the
president Air Force One this is Andrew's
Air Force based air traffic control
please acknowledge
over Air Force One come
in oh my
God we're still Gathering Intel we're
coordinating the search for survivors
for bodies nise
pres
hi you play the king of agent Myers one
inch at a
time now tell
me do you think I'm
[Music]
lying
yourself what
[Music]
happens sooner or later he will make a
mistake and it'll be the last mistake he
ever
[Music]
makes
we got some fresh fish fell welcome to
my jail
son you're in here cuz they say you got
to pay I'm in here to make sure you do
congratulations Adams you our father
nobody told you you're going to spend a
rest of your life in here you ain't
never going to see
that truth is I never thought about
being a
father he's your little Mama's Boy you
know you don't have to be like him right
but I just want to be there for my
[Music]
kid if Freedom's a state of mind I guess
my dream should be
enough just think about how much better
your kids going to be without you
around
bco when you going to grow
up I ain't content with
dreaming
humans are the greatest weakness in any
security system prisons aren't
inescapable they just meant to feel that
way the street crime my mind need your
help I know the game bro 23 Deep when
you sleep even theind man can see you
think reading's going to save your ass
no I do not sir I'm stry have at I'm so
close to not only freedom but also to
being a real
father I would like to help you I go
there more than anything in the world
I'm
think
I I'm
[Music]
think I'm thinking
Master you can only protect yourself by
your
[Music]
choices
my bridesmaid entrances are the stuff of
Legends ever the bridesmaid that is my
badge of honor you feel me I feel
you I go to weddings and baby showers
every damn weekend when are you going to
give me grandkids talk to your firstborn
about grandchildren I don't want him
procreating no that's a terrifying
thought nobody wants that nobody wants
that I don't have a man or any legit
prospects what have I ever done am I not
suitable for life you are very suitable
for Life feel like I'm running out of
time are you you seeing anyone now I'm
seeing everyone now it's sort of an all
you can eat buffet how old are you
please say 32 or 33 lelly I'm
stupid I want you to remember they can
be a never Neverland Never Growing Up
never aging but those eggs they
are if I don't spend 13k to freeze my
eggs I might never be able to have kids
meanwhile you're going to wait till
you're 70 to have a baby with an
influencer that is accurate and I'm not
embarrassed about it what's new with you
Nelly I'm thinking about getting my eggs
frozen that's amazing maybe I should
have a baby shower but you're not having
a
baby what if I screw this up I don't
even know if I want kids I've seen
Euphoria you're not going to screw this
[Music]
up you're buying time someone who's good
enough for you is hard to come by don't
need anybody else I'm either going
through a Renaissance or amidst the
worst crisis of my
lifetime here we go down here you look
like I'd say fortun definitely not
[Applause]
okay on three big breath in
[Music]
Waverly hi Auntie what are you doing
here I haven't had time off since met
school so now is my chance before I
started my
residency I haven't told my
[Music]
parents get made it hi you're Rachel's
neighbor I'm I'm Blake nice to meet
[Music]
you
is she
okay are you okay I'm okay are you okay
me morning hi you can't swim huh I kind
of missed that as a kid I could teach
you why are you doing this like spending
time with you
I tell me about your parents I've been
doing in 4 years they make sure I have
everything that I need but they don't
really know me to
are you looking at me
no I kind of have feelings for Blake no
kidding here you are having the best
summer of your life going after a boy
you like I think I see love birds she's
thinking about moving here it's just so
rain hi Mom Dr Wong squeez you into his
research team this is a for your future
my parents want me in Toronto I'm not
normally very
impulsive can we just stay in the
[Music]
moment Bly you lied to us I want to stay
here with you but I do want to be a
doctor I don't have to act like this is
anything more than
summerling it's time you ask yourself
what you want to do I don't want the
summer to end you have to make yourself
known in this life not for anyone
else but for you want to be
[Music]
[Applause]
with we H the r
Lo
[Music]
atson
F what you have got
[Music]
Turon
dear
[Music]
[Applause]
f
[Music]
let's rob a bank do what
now they cannot get
away once upon a time I was just a wee
boy work at post office don't asked you
for 6 months to chop that freaking yeti
off your head get it
gone D girl of my dreams marmalade you
going to show me right or
what from then on we was
[Music]
Inseparable my mom they raise the price
of her medicine overnight I say when the
system fails you great your own damn
sister half a million dollar WR K we got
to take this serious
in oh God Dam dear sweet Lord we are
scared it's time we start kicking back
get him the
CL baby I was just
playing i't no
criminal I've been chasing her for 2
years hey you see Mama's peels she's
just as much m M no too
stop can't tell if you're being
[Music]
[Applause]
honest it's me and you against whole
[Music]
world